[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic hello chess fans and
welcome back to st. Louis I'm Ben Simon
here at the fall chess classic the
strong Invitational seasonal tournament
we have two groups here a and B 210
player round robins to be contested over
nine days nine rounds in classical chess
many of these players sit just below of
what you would call the world elite
level and many of them miss out on
sponsorships because they just miss that
arbitrary threshold the chess club's
quarterly tournaments provide an
opportunity for these players to play
strong tournaments for a large prize
fund and get exposure from the chess
world the fields combined have a prize
fund of 36 thousand dollars the top
prize in Group A is 6 grand the top
prize in Group B is 4 grand we play one
classical round of chess every day
through Thursday September 14 rounds
begin at 1:00 p.m. here in st. Louis
except for the last day which begins
earlier I'm with daro spirits here in
round one of Group A play and today with
the white pieces he defeated Daniel
narrowed its key one of the most emotive
players in all of chess
does that ever throw you off the
expressions he makes during those games
I understand paid too much attention I
was just playing my game and trying to
present as I can and I mean I didn't pay
attention right yeah I mean I he's a
camera man's dream I'll tell you why you
just love to get his reactions he's like
Kasparov with his reactions to what's on
the board and maybe you can show us what
exactly he was reacting to in this game
ok maybe I can do it like that my idea
is this this and this and try to
exchange this bishop somehow improve and
in many many cases
the pond on a 3 would be exchanged for
the prom on b5 and this is pornhub okay
is some some position like that I lost
to Vera Cobian in last tournament here
in San Luis but I mean with black but
but it's some chances for right so it's
not like in dead draw sit zero-sum play
rugby DSO hippo rugby dat should be 7
and here I think this was mistake
Rudi 7 because he he doesn't recognize 7
is kind of annoying I think and he
should try to exchange and therefore the
way to do that was route d7 rook e8 take
take and here he again comes back to the
tube and we have some kind of similar
position as before we should be freaking
a ranking you want Chris of d1 and some
sense again and so on but he played this
and now maybe still was rude e8 the best
move we could not allow me to improve my
Midas rook my organ from c1 but he
played King h7 very quickly and here I
think it's already not very difficult
position like that say Luke c7 and here
I can play for example Roxy one and I
mean I'm finding myself but there is
this Bishop b4 check fret so gets to do
something about it and I play rook c5 or
something like that of let's say g6 or
whatever than rook c5 and this looks
very dangerous for for black or
something like that anyways if rook d6 I
know now I just start keep start
attacking his pawns
f5 here's to the semi just he couldn't
played this King g6
because rope a7 he is imposed f5 Roxy 1
and now if he doesn't try drugs now
let's say hip goes this for chasing a
free pond and I just go for me Roxy 7
room d1 let's taking which to rogue f2
okay seven and time mating humanity 7
and I'm faster
but keep i drugged you one will just
correct but the difference is that I do
not have my rogue on a one but like in
previous blinds like let's say where is
it
no not here like earlier like here for
example I have my here I have my rogue
on I want and in this position
as in the game I have my rook on a8
which is which is doing very good job
here in attacking all his pawns and not
only attacking his pawns but creating a
seat up here in the game mating that for
his King
he played with e2 just logical King g3
if five and this was maybe ok maybe it
was mistake maybe positions already just
lost
I mean the point is that besides let's
say that I can attack his pawn on e6 but
he never could say even if I pick some
random of h4 okay don't worry run away
h5 of course but let's say if he plays
this ok h5 is of course winning but the
point is that I have B should be 5 and
he weeping I win by this pin and if if
I've it appears that I have very strong
move rook is 6 which I really like and
the point is that Bishop d6 next and
very silly I created mating that here
and then now it's different now it's
visible the difference of bishop is
visual money is much stronger which only
four so yeah rogue a6f fourth probably
only move take stays was kind of logical
King Jeffrey Raghav 8a Bishop d6 King J
we reach time control and I think rookie
6 is the most precise move Bishop b3
Ruby 5 and here if he would have played
Bishop c4 I have additional option I
mean basically mutation being just the
best which opiate just hit his rocker I
can't defend on b5 and and it can't die
every pound as well and just collect on
b5 and the same happens after Bishop f4
but after rook b8 and started thinking
here because I had to make decision
either to play either Bishop ending or
maybe some rook ending like for example
Bishop d3 Bishop c4 takes takes I
believe this is still winning for
example Ruby free rook she freed and
King comes but I thought I believed that
yet is the simplest here solution
because I managed to put my king only
five and his pawn on d5 is very weak so
and his object of my attack and this
should be winning king of four king of a
bishop c6 g5 king g5 King 7 and now the
program of Jesus g3 just in order in
order not to allow any contra play like
for example would be case let's say
after King g7 I play some random of shot
before then my son Bishop f1 I don't and
I have my pawns on right square so I did
immediately got rid of all spawns long
vice course and push to exchange one of
them but like I don't have any
weaknesses that he can kind of make
control play maybe shot with one H for
this this shop c4 we showed before I
mean this is this mean because I have
much Burger King and I just I'm coming
to this b5 pawn either to this h6 or any
one of all spawns who will collapse if
kin d7 King before I mean maybe
something else was better but I don't
know let's say we should be to deny even
I can play either King f5 working d5
both moves are completing I was I think
in d5 massive modular I get to c5 and a
pretty shot Sigma should be 5 must be
mean but King the southern kingdom
disease and I for I think is the
simplest because we shall be free also I
mean I didn't want to kind of there are
lots of I mean I think it's winning up
because it was h5 move I mean it must be
winning but why - even better ends with
some pawn endings here and if just a 4
is completely winning on the spot and he
doesn't have any moves
basically like Bishop e2 then I'll just
a 5 and I'm winning basically because
King c7 king c5 or either if not walking
around bishops is equipped XB v soon but
after Bishop e6 I just take the pawn and
here he resigned because it's a stop
this pawn goes to b7 and
kiss King has to defend this is like
from I mean most product from promotion
and then for example they say show 57 v6
some random move King g5 King comes here
to this h6 pawn and I'm just two pawns
up I might give this b7 powers
completely winning anyways so yeah this
was this was the game he resigned after
a takes b5 a fine performance in the
first round there yeah thank you I like
this I like how I play today I'm quite
satisfied I'm satisfied with the way I
played so I'm looking forward to the
next games well I know that everything
just picked up as far as the school year
goes at st. Louis University how are
things going with the slew team well we
just had one meeting so far because
you know it's it's be everyone's busy
with the first weeks and our team kind
of got a little bit bigger we got two
new players to our team who are doors a
direction if from Iran and Alexander
repot off well known here yeah and so
yeah I mean let's see how we will
definitely work on our chess and we hope
to get better and then in Panem's we we
definitely want to improve the last
three years result right well the
franchise is definitely still building
Congrats on that win once again and
let's take a look at the standings
you're welcome by the way at Group A
after round number one Alexander she
Manav is tied at the top with Derril
spirits tomorrow's game to watch has to
be daro as black taking on Grandmaster
Roofing Lee it's the first round and I'm
sitting here with angel a rebus from
Spain playing in the Fall Classic today
with the white pieces he was able to
dispatch of Akshay Andhra one of the
hometown favorites congratulations angel
so far on this win off to a good start
and what maybe we could describe his
Redemption but take us through this game
and show us any notable parts
okay so d-4d for just normal now it's
kind of playing well for this time out
first again and also against this Bishop
which is here and that's nothing so I
move like f5 and
if if I could ever play a five-degree
shop good never play and also I'm out
betrayed in f6 so this look a little be
bad and also he came to waste a lot of
time he here like two minutes for this
position for like 60 moves so it was
pretty bad for him he had to play this
position this crazy position really fast
so he ran for the big Queen d7 is the
the most natural move he wants to go
Quincy for at some point actually now
so I played King h2 to defend the pawn
also with the idea Bishop e3 for example
now 24 lost spot
I'll just take and play Bishop e3 and
the Queen's drop so he could he could
drive if EF Jia from 24
I guess not the quest not trap but I
feel after Queen f2 I'm trading the
night and Trillium Bishop h3 again I
feel like he's in trouble again so he
well he actually made something here
he should have probably played eight
force and like that to try to complicate
the position try to somehow make my King
unsafe but it's still unclear I didn't
even have an ID again stage 4 probably
sound like Queen f2 or Bishop e3 and
Hawk in d3 but he played a 5 which is
very weird with because it's like
dropping the pawn one morning he told me
after the game that he thought that the
the Queen was still on the 8th and he
could take 25 but he has I hear like 30
seconds at this point so he was playing
with the increment so if I if I feel
should be losing already just taken a
five now at this point is like really
strong even in an endgame if we drag
queens or anything at this point with
the bishops it's like really strong so
he went before 94 and well III feel here
is kind of lost already it's a matter of
finding a couple of good moves that I
think I did
so Queenie six look like the most
natural move again trying to pin this
night trying to go for b3 so P so page
three and now he has to take a decision
again either Koch Quinn g8 and still
keep the the pink here but the the Queen
on g8 looks pretty we apply something
like a six P 324 should be winning with
this poem a six so he went for Quincy
six which is probably the best move
trying to take on if we're trying to go
for p3 there now they Foursquare is
covered by a queen so now b3 is a real
threat so because I would be losing the
night so now I had to make the decision
to taking here Bishop takes pawn takes
and f5 and I felt in the game this
patient should be winning but I also
felt that he had some counter play and
it wasn't gonna be easy
so b3 is the only move I feel also he
forced me to go Queen e2 to defend a
knight and now I think well I think if
he if he had a little bit more time he
could have been able to find something
because I feel something like d3 at some
point if we take only three group d8 and
then we need to something like cruelty
for rook c8 I feel like black could find
something maybe here up c8 directly
trying to try to open this try to open
up this D file and then try to do
something maybe with the Queen and c2 or
something like that and make make use of
this poin b3 but he didn't have time
his blunder in one he has played rogue
fc8 which is just loosening one because
he didn't say that I take here and I
it's made into if he takes a knife let's
check my here so now he's forced to take
on usage of the Queen and I've just
taken the rogue and it's just watching
he playing a few more moves but just a
six which is pretty strong well probably
any other move is going to but this a
six is like committing check check
could be six and nine three Crockett six
and we need to look after and he can
stop to make here so I think he just
blinded because of the time mainly this
a5 after ba5 if I should be winning for
white and then here he had our chance
well I don't know if it's a chance
actually but I think this I feel this d3
is the only move here to try to do
something and like he didn't have times
didn't say fortunately for me well
action is one of those players who is
unfortunately kind of infamous for
getting into time trouble consistently
well angel you're off to a good start
one point the last time you played here
at the st. Louis chess club you said it
was less than satisfactory do you feel
like you have something to prove at this
event
well actually the the funny thing is the
last time I play here I also started
winning the first round I beat this
American down
it's called his name is faith well I
started winning the game - he's like
2424 50 something like that he's very
young and I started winning then somehow
I made a few draws and I started loading
so hopefully this year I'm not as busy
as I was last year with the University
we just started basically so I don't
have exams and they just have to prepare
and projects so I'm I I'll try to focus
on try to show my best well that's all
we can ask
angel congratulations on your first
round win let's take a look at the group
B standings after the first round Angel
Arriba's joins two other players with
one point in Group B tomorrow two of
those players meet as Nisha kun takes on
Alejandra Ramirez each rounds notable
players will be interviewed in this
recap but remember to follow the games
live every day at 1:00 p.m. in st. Louis
via chess 24 and us chess champs dot-com